>> Sean: LAST NIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM WE HAD HUGE NEWS
WITH THE HILL'S JOHN SOLOMON
BREAKING THE NEWS BRUCE OHR
UNDER OATH IN CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY REVEALING TO HIGH
RANKING DOJ FBI OFFICIALS
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND
THE DOES YEA WAS IN FACT
CORRECTED AND PAID FOR BY
CLINTON.
VERY WELL WOULD BE
POLITICALLY BIASED.
OUR OWN GREGG JARRETT NOW
EXPLORES THE MAJOR LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS IN HIS
NEW ARTICLE ENTITLED OUT ON
FRIENDS@FOXNEWS.COM,
MUELLER'S TEAM KNEWS TO YEA
KICKING OFF TRUMP
INVESTIGATION WAS BIASED AND
DEFECTIVE.
HERE TO DISCUSS DETAILS OF
THE NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER
ILLICIT SCHEME TO CLEAR
HILLARY CLINTON AND FRAME
DONALD TRUMP.
GREGG JARRETT.
SIDNEY POWELL IS WITH US.
GREGG, LET'S START WITH YOUR
COLUMN.
IN AUGUST OF 2016, BRUCE OHR
WARNS EVERYBODY, ALL THE
PEOPLED IN
PEOPLE UIN
PEOPLE UPPER ECHELON AND
DOJ.
>> AND DOJ.
>> Sean: WARNS THEM HILLARY
CLINTON PAID FOR THIS BIASED
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATES
TRUMP.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THEY KNEW IT'S PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON AND
DO ANYTHING TO STOP DONALD
TRUMP.
THEY SHOULD HAVE DROPPED IT
THEREFORE IN THE TRASH CAN.
THEY DIDN'T.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS GOLD.
WE DON'T CARE IF IT'S PHONY
OR NOT.
WE WILL USE IT AS A PRETEXT
TO FRAME DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: RUSSIAN LIES PAID
FOR.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: WHO DOES BRUCE OHR
TELL?
>> NOW CONFIRMED I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CONFIRM AS WELL MUCH
OF HIS DEPOSITION TESTIMONY,
HE IMPLICATES TWO TOP
OFFICIALS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WHO ARE NOW ON
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S TEAM
OF ARTISANS AND TWO OTHERS
AT THE FBI WHO ARE ON IT WHO
HAVE SINCE LEFT.
HAVE YOU OFTEN ASKED ME WHY
ISN'T MUELLER INVESTIGATING
THE FBI AND DOJ FOR HILLARY
RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
I THINK WE NOW KNOW THE
ANSWER, FOUR PEOPLE ON HIS
OWN PANEL WERE IMPLICATED.
>> Sean: INCLUDING ONE
ANDREW WEISSMANN WE TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
>> ANDREW WEISSMANN AND OF
COURSE THE LISA PAGE AND
PETER STRZOK WERE ON ON.
THEY ALL KNEW IN THE SUMMER
OF 2016 THAT THIS CASE WAS
SUSPECT.
>> Sean: SO IF HE IS
SUPPOSEDLY LOOKING AT
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE,
HILLARY PAYS FOR RUSSIAN
LIES ABOUT HER OPPONENT THAT
THEY ARE PEDDLING, EVEN WE
HAVE OUR OWN INTEL COMMUNITY
PEDDLING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: THEY DO IT TO STEAL
AN ELECTION AND THEN TO GET
A FISA WARRANT.
WHY AREN'T ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE EVER INVESTIGATED?
WHERE IS THE GRAND JURY IN
WHEN IS SOMEBODY GOING TO DO
THEIR JOB?
>> BECAUSE YOU HAD THE
INCOMPETENT AND FECKLESS
JEFF SESSIONS IN CHARGE AND
ROD ROSENSTEIN WHO SIGNED
OFF ON ONE OF THE FISA
WARRANTS IMPROPERLY.
HE HAS BEEN OBSTRUCTING EVER
SINCE.
SESSIONS IS GOING, ROD
ROSENSTEIN SOON GONE AND
WILLIAM BARR WILL BECOME THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I AM FAIRLY CONFIDENT HE
WILL INVESTIGATE.
>> Sean: IF HE DOESN'T THEN
WE ARE A BANANA REPUBLIC.
YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT ANDREW
WEISSMANN BECAUSE YOU WROTE
ABOUT HIM.
IS HE MUELLER'S PIT BULL.
HE KNEW ABOUT THIS AND THEY
ARE LOOKING INTO RUSSIA
COLLUSION AND THEY NEVER
TOUCH THIS?
SEAN I'M SURE MR. WEISSMANN
MIGHT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED AND
MIGHT HAVE HELPED DRAFT THE
FISA APPLICATIONS HE MIGHT
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT IT FROM THE
FIRST CONVERSATION HE HAD
WITH CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THIS KIND OF FABRICATION IS
RIGHT UP MR. WISEMAN'S ALLEY
AS YOU KNOW FROM READING
"LICENSE TO LIE" YOURSELF.
IS HE VERY GOOD AT MAKING UP
CRIMES AND THE FACTUAL
NARRATIVE HE WANTS TO SUIT
WHATEVER CRIME HE WANTS TO
CHARGE.
THAT'S HIS STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE.
WHILE HE HAS THE EVIDENCE
THAT SHOWS PEOPLE ARE
INNOCENT.
>> Sean: REMEMBER, BRUCE
OHR, AFTER STEELE IS FIRED
FOR LYING AND LEAKING BY THE
FBI.
THEY STILL WANTED MORE
CONTACT WITH HIM CONTACT WAS
BRUCE OHR.
WRITING HIS CONTACT WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE LYING
ABOUT THIS PHONY DOSSIER
THAT NOW IS DEBUNK GIVING
INFORMATION TO BRUCE OHR TO
FUNNEL TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
HIMSELF.
WE HAVE THAT EVIDENCE.
>> OH, YEAH.
YES.
AND I THINK THIS GOES BACK
FARTHER THAN THAT, SEAN.
I THINK IT GOES BACK TO 2015
WHEN COMEY GAVE ILLEGAL
ACCESS TO THE RAW NSA DATA
TO THREE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS.
I WOULD BET THAT ONE OF
THOSE IS FUSION GPS AND THAT
THEY WERE MINING THAT DATA
TO CREATE THIS PHONEY
DOSSIER WITH CHRISTOPHER
STEELE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND THEN RECYCLED 2 THROUGH
HIM.
>> Sean: TWO YEARS HAS BEEN
TRUMP-RUSSIA.
THEY KNEW FROM THE GET-GO
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES THAT WERE
DISSEMINATED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THEN THEY USED
THOSE LIES THAT THEY KNEW
WERE LIES, NEVER VERIFIED
IT.
IF THEY WOULD HAVE DONE
THEIR JOB, THEY SIGN OFF ON
IT AS GOSPEL TRUTH TO GET A
WARRANT.
SHRED THE CONSTITUTION,
SHRED THE FOURTH AMENDMENT
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE AND THEY ARE THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF LOOKING
INTO RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
>> EXACTLY THEY LIED TO THE
FISA COURT AND
MR. ROSENSTEIN SIGNED THE
APPLICATION AND MR. COMEY
SIGNED THE APPLICATIONS.
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO SIGNED
THOSE APPLICATIONS AS WELL
WHOSE NAMES HAVE BEEN
REDACTED.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO THOSE
PEOPLE ARE THE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT
MR. MUELLER STARTED SHOULD
HAVE BEEN OF THOSE PEOPLE
AND NEVER OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AT ALL.
IT'S EGREGIOUS GOVERNMENT
MISCONDUCT.
THE MUELLER WITCH-HUNT
SHOULD BE ENDED IMMEDIATELY
AND THE ENTIRE TEAM
DISBANDED.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT BE
INVESTIGATED.
I DON'T KNOW, SEAN, I MEAN,
I'M STILL CONCERNED ABOUT
MR. BARR'S PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH
MR. MUELLER.
>> Sean: SO AM I.
YOU ARE NOT?
>> LOOK, THE BOTTOM LINE
HERE THERE WAS NO TRUMP
COLLUSION BUT THERE WAS
HILLARY FBI DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE COLLUSION AND FOUR
PEOPLE ON MUELLER'S SPECIAL
COUNSEL TEAM INVOLVED.